there's a man in my house sitting on my
couch talking to mama look I don't have
jealousy issues but hypothetically
speaking if a man or a woman walks into
my house and he or she happens to have a
dick yeah we might have a problem yeah
that that is exactly why all my male
friends think that you hate them that's
funny because I do hate them really nice
oh my god so who do we have here a
little shindig a little rendezvous this
is my friend Colleen oh I'm sorry it's
Colleen Bernice Kelly okay Oh put him
like that he might as well whip out his
dick and put it on my head
okay baby listen that's what I have to
do because if I don't other men like
Patrice are gonna come in flip out their
disgusting little balls table what does
that mean back it up back it up oh my
god conversations listen hey Leif can I
ask you a question what brings you to my
house well you
girlfriend or something huh wife kids
concubine education no I'm actually
saying yeah you would be [ __ ] hey honey
tater tots cootchie crumbles can you get
me and my new best friend something to
eat real quick I'll be right back I'm
gonna grab us some snacks you feel a
little uncomfortable
yeah man you meet you no no no listen
how about this i'ma just this is what we
call an icebreaker
it's called danca dick no hell are you
weird man
hey no no no tell them why you sent me
to the kitchen listen I'm on say [ __ ]
the hot dog taco system does not work
that's funny you have any scientific
backing to prove that statement right
there ah do you Bill Nye the Science Guy
honey can you come in here for a second
don't you know what I'm okay what I'm
gonna do is get to know my friend
Shanice a little bit more but I could
really use your help get over here
I'm not asking him if he wants a hot dog
or a damn talker okay you're gonna do it
you know why because I'm a picky little
pretty ass out and by the way he looks
exactly like your brother you sick
[ __ ] freak um she doesn't look like
my brother he looks like Caillou if
Caillou had like a tan and a beard but
that's beside the point
how is asking someone if they want a
taco or hotdog supposed to [ __ ] their
day or not it's insane hot day hot dog
or taco taco I guess yeah [ __ ] my wife
what yes
taco exactly he likes [ __ ] you got what
he tried [ __ ] oh my god
no even if even if this ridiculous fast
food test did work so what what then I
just can't have a male friend no you can
have no friends okay
they like dick no I'm going to kill you
yes he's having dirty thoughts about you
right now
oh how do you know that did you have
dirty thoughts about me when we first
met because correct me if I'm wrong but
I remember you saying you fell in love
with my mind of course I did [ __ ] I was
picturing you Nate fine I'll just never
have another male friend ever again
there's no I'm saying of liquids okay
I'm a man right which means I have
constant dirty thoughts I know what
other men are thinking hot be nasty [ __ ]
about you 24/7 we're married
so you just walk around all day
picturing with maybe a horse I be
telling you that you need to go
apologize to him yeah I'm gonna go do no
hell no if you don't go apologize to him
right now for the rest of your life
you'll be doing just that picturing me
naked
oh you think you scare me you think I
don't wax my dick off every night
huh I don't need you [ __ ] alright so I
met nothing to apologize to do cuz
that's what men do she ever tell me to
do [ __ ]
it's on me he met